اشاره القياده تتسبب بمشكله في باريس داني
الفيس يستعينو بمحم ميسي وجمهور يوفنتوس
يهدد النقل التلفزيون في ايطاليا هذه
الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
اشاره القياده في مباراه سان جيرمان
الاخيره
صفوف الفريق حيث اكد القائد الثاني سابقا
ان الاداره لم تخبرهم بان كيليان اصبح
القائد الثاني للفريق
على الانستغرام
نبقى مع اخباري سان جيرمان حيث افادت
تقريرون اعلاميه عن رفض ليونيل ميسي للعرض
الاول المقدم لاداره نادي الفرنسي وهذا
بحاسب الصحافه المختص في اخبار برشلونه
جيرارد روميرو قال روميرو في بث على تويتش
بان الفوز بكاس العالم غير نظره ميسي الذي
لا ينوي الان تمديد بقائه في العاصمه
باريس ويتجه نحو الخروج من سنجرمان
في مصارعه الاحداث مع النجم البرازيلي
داني الفيس في قضيه اعتدائه على امراه في
نادي ليلي بمدينه برشلونه
وبعد الصدمه التي تلقها نادي يوفنتوس بخصم
15 نقطه من رصيده اقدم العديد من مشجع
بالغاء اشتراكاتهم مع المنصات والقنوات
الناقله لمسابقه الدوري داخل ايطاليا
احتجاجا على العقوبه التي سلطت على فريقهم
ومن المتوقع ان تصل خسائر النقل
التلفزيوني الى 136 مليون يورو ان الغى
نحو 500,000 شخص اشتراكهم مع الناقلين
للكاتشو